[Music]
there are plenty of reasons why Paton
list chose to leave the Disney Channel
show bunks but one of them isn't what
you'd expect keep watching to find out
the real reason why Emma Ross left camp
kikiwaka once and for all I'm really
gonna miss you guys
especially you besties Peyton list has
come a long way from being the young
Disney star she used to be and in a way
she owes this all to her decision to
leave the cast of bunked and explore new
avenues in the summer of 2018
Hayden shocked her fans when she
announced that she was working on
filming her last few episodes for the
popular Disney series at this point
Peyton was 20 years old and looking for
a way to reinvent her image and what
better way to do that than to get rid of
your old one since Peyton chose to leave
the show before the series came to an
end many of her fans suspected that she
was going through something major or
maybe that she was taking on a new
project that prevented her from
continuing on as Emma Ross but that
wasn't the case in the end Peyton just
wanted out at the Disney Channel during
an interview with Jess jarred jr. Peyton
opened up about her decision she
confessed that she felt that she had
aged out of children's shows but she was
quick to add that she still loves all
those people from the show according to
Payton's they are and will always be her
family it's perfectly normal for young
stars to get their big break on the
Disney Channel but it's not very common
for them to stay there in a way Disney
Channel is a stepping stone for aspiring
actors and at some point or another
they're going to make the choice to
leave Peyton made it clear that she was
done acting in kid shows but some fans
were shocked to find out that she was
done with the Disney Channel as a whole
Peyton's departure marks the end of an
era actors like dove Cameron Skye
Jackson Cameron Boyce and more have also
confirmed that they'll be moving on from
the Disney Channel once their current
projects wrap up but Payton wasn't
quitting Disney and going into the world
willy-nilly nope the Jessie's star had
plans to make it big elsewhere and some
of these plans included a guest starring
role on the CBS comedy Happy Together
which happened to have Harry Styles as
an executive producer back in the summer
of 2018 Payton had also already taken
the role of Olivia Richmond on
hulu series light as a feather however
payton also had her eyes set on an even
bigger prize the celebrity was eager to
branch out into the fashion market and
soon did so when she launched her
fashion line list i'm super fashion
woman faster than an airport mani-pedi
more powerful than a platinum charge
card if there's one thing payton got in
the bag its fashion so it wasn't too
shocking to find out that the young
celebrity was launching her very own
fashion brands back in 2018
list by payton is yet another reason why
the Disney Channel star chose to leave
her roots behind in the end juggling a
fashion line new acting gigs and Disney
shows just wasn't on her agenda on top
of that Peyton wanted her clothing brand
to appeal to the older crowd and leaving
Disney behind ensured that her young
fans would continue dressing age
appropriately Peyton's fashion line is
definitely geared toward young adults so
it would make sense that she would want
to leave the children's shows behind
list also totally embodies Peyton's love
for fashion and showcases her very own
personal style
according to her her fashion line
encompasses numerous styles from
business meetings to girls night outs
another recent payton chose to leave the
disney channel back in 2018 has a lot to
do with her age and fear of being
typecast
it's common for actors to play the same
type of role for years only to have
trouble being cast in a different type
of role in the future this can put a
bitter halt on their career then Peyton
just didn't want this she was excited to
shed her Disney skin and experiment with
new roles and thrilling movies for
Peyton 2019 s the first year that she
won't be participating in a Disney
Channel production and well she's
thrilled about it but the actress is
aware that auditioning for rambunctious
roles just isn't the way to go
more often than not Disney stars will
try to snag startling roles to break out
of the Disney mold but that's just not
what Peyton's about in fact she finds
this to be a little cliche instead
Peyton's reading tons of scripts and
simply going after the ones that
resonates with her on top of that
Peyton's looking for ways to explore her
musical talents and since she didn't
really get to sing on bunk'd she figured
it was time to throw in her towel and it
all worked out in 2018 Payton was cast
as faith in the movie anthem of a
teenage prophet and her song
and dance until we die was featured in
the film despite being a seasoned
actress Payton admitted to feeling super
nervous about releasing her music turns
out singing in front of a crowd makes
her feel a lot more vulnerable than
acting does but that hasn't stopped her
yet
that sounds like a challenge I like a
challenge
Payton made the decision to leave the
cast of bunk'd in 2018 and it goes
without saying that the choice is paying
off Payton's 2019 lineup is jam-packed
and she's finally going after roles that
challenge her in the ends Payton chose
to leave the disney channel simply
because she felt that she had outgrown
it she wanted to explore new venues
break out of the disney mold and explore
fashion and singing so what do you think
of Payton's decision to move on from
Disney were you upset when she left the
cast of bunk'd sound off in the comments
section for more videos about your
favorite Disney Channel stars subscribe
to the things and don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up while you're
at it thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]